Say you're given a mesh like this. Some statue standing on a platform that's
some distance from the origin. You'd like to rotate it in place on its base so
that it's facing like this. You know that if you just try to rotate it, it's
going to rotate around the origin and it will swing wildly in position. You want
it to stay where it is. You have a few matrices at hand to perform the task.
You're given a translation matrix that would move the center of the model's base
to the origin. You also have a rotation matrix that will rotate the model or
anything else around the y-axis. Finally, you can also invert the translation
and rotation matrices. The question is, what series of transforms will rotate
the model on its base? In other words, we want to end up with the object in the
same position, but rotated around its own axis. Put the transforms in the usual
right to left order, rightmost being applied to the object first. If you don't
need all four slots for matrices, just leave the leftmost ones empty. For
example, if you needed just a single transform, put it in this rightmost slot.
To solve this one, you might want to remember the rule, once a transform is
applied, forget about it and just think about where the model itself is then.